what's up guys the Apple event just
ended so we're gonna chat about the new
MacBook Pros that they launched and a
few other things that they talked about
in the event we look pretty short
defense I felt like I mean I think we
all knew that this was basically just an
event focusing on the MacBook Pros I
thought there might be some other things
I always hope that there's going to be
one more thing but I think the one more
thing is is no more still cross my
fingers every event and just hope and
just help so here's the new MacBook Pro
it comes in two sizes two colors 15 inch
and a 13 inch and the silver that we're
all used to and the Space Gray which the
color itself isn't new but for the
MacBook Pros it is new one of the
biggest differences here is the touch
bar so what's cool about the touch bar
is it will change with each application
that you open on your computer so here's
some of the different use cases so for
photos you can scroll through and you
can also edit and rotate and do all
kinds of different things that normally
I mean you would just do them it's not a
percent not necessary but it's a hundred
percent cool here's some uses for final
cut scrubbing the timeline that's going
to be really cool for me like I'm pretty
excited about that I do wish that this
bar was moved closer to the trackpad
basically kind of like the little tiny
bar that pops up here for mail whatever
you're on your iPhone and you're typing
it kind of gives you a little
autocorrect and things that it thinks
that you're going to say sorry this is
what I really liked in Safari you can go
through and you can switch tabs so you
can just click and it gives you a little
preview of each one key notes I don't
really ever make keynote presentations
but if I did this would all be very very
helpful you can also customize it to
anything that you might want it to be so
if there's things that you use more
often than others you can just drag and
drop those in so that's pretty cool 130
percent faster and percent faster flash
storage ten hours of battery life of
course I think the last one they said it
was also ten hours of battery life but
if you're doing high processor-intensive
things like video editing or any types
of stuff like that it definitely does
lower your battery life so I feel like
you'll probably get maybe half of that
maybe some new speakers here's the
problem for me
and for a lot of people the most
versatile port ever Thunderbolt 3 so
there's four different ports thankfully
they left us a headphone jack thank you
unfortunately they did remove the SD
card reader and for a lot of people who
do video production who are
photographers most of those people we
all use these SD card slots quite a lot
and it is so convenient to have that
port just readily accessible throw that
card in and you're ready to go well
that's removed and they only have these
four Thunderbolt three ports which
thankfully they are compatible with USB
see they also remove the MagSafe charger
and for me the MagSafe has saved my
computer's lives so many times and I'm a
little bit nervous to see how that goes
the USB Secord that it charges with is
really stiff so it's not kind of that
loose cord that you're used to having
with your other chargers I'm hoping that
they do make MagSafe USB C charger that
would be incredible the upside that
though is you can charge from any of the
ports so any of those slots you're able
to charge from which is great but let's
MagSafe in love you can simultaneously
connect to 5k displays to raid systems
Thunderbolt my guys so you basically can
just create like this crazy workstation
off of this little guy
so the 13-inch starts at $14.99 all the
way up to 1999 and the 15-inch $23.99 to
$27.99 you can get these in the Space
Gray or the silver I ended up getting
the 15-inch Space Gray so I'm excited to
see what that looks like I've never had
the Space Gray before so it's a nice
little change all in all I think the
MacBook is going to be a huge upgrade
especially for me for editing I'm a
little bit concerned about the lack of
ports because I do use those so often
for so many different things so I ended
up having to get all of the adapters for
my hard drive for now an SD card reader
fact that it is a lot smaller is going
to be pretty awesome and I'm hoping that
that kind of makes up for the fact that
they removed all of the ports and now
I'm gonna have to carry a lot of extra
things with me but I think that
eventually we'll all get over it it's
just going to take some time here you
are some different examples of using the
touch bar you can accept face times
right from the touch bar another thing
that was pretty cool is you can use
touch ID so they mentioned this in the
apple event where you can use touch ID
eels with multiple people they didn't
say how many people you could do it up
to but if you have guest accounts on
your MacBook Pro you can just have
someone come up touch it and it'll
switch to their account that's a pretty
cool feature nobody else uses my macbook
so I don't really have to use that but
you can also use Apple pay and there she
is
the new MacBook Pro your side-by-side
the 15 inch and the 13 inch the 13 is
nice I like it a lot but for editing and
other things I definitely more screen
space so a couple of other cool
highlights that happened during the
event Tim was talking about the new
Apple TV app that they're calling TV
which is I don't know you just basically
called it what it is so I mean that
works for me they talked about Minecraft
on Apple TV they also showed this really
cool demo of Apple TV which will as you
can see here Twitter showing a demo with
Apple TV app which can show an NFL game
alongside of live tweets news and more
that's kind of cool because it really is
a whole new way to watch TV most of us
who watch TV myself included at least
this is how I watch TV I'm on Twitter
the entire time reading what other
people are talking about so it was cool
about this as they were showing live
tweets of people at the game live
periscopes of people reacting to this so
it's adding this full other element of
live TV right onto your TV my favorite
quote ever we want Apple TV to be the
one place to access all of your
television today we're announcing a new
app and we simply call it TV so they did
a demo of the new Apple TV stuff and
they were talking about this week
marking the 25th anniversary of their
first notebook October 25th seventy
percent thinner 2x larger trackpad and
basically the rest of the event was just
talking about the mac books it just felt
like there should have been something
else I really thought they were going to
announce another thing they did talk
about one of the LG displays here
is a department LG to make a 5k monitor
powered by USB C so that's that right
there but that's it so I think that
probably crushes all of the hopes and
dreams that we all may have had that
Apple was going to release another
display I feel like at this point it
doesn't really make sense for them when
they just had somebody else create this
one for them so that's a new MacBook Pro
I'd love to know what you guys think of
it I think it's pretty cool I'm still
waiting patiently for the air pods to be
released it was supposed to be that late
October it's October 27th don't think
that's happening clearly anytime soon
we'll see you guys in the next video
have a great day peace we've got a new
gate in town guys I am excited to bring
you crack gate that's what I'm calling
it so the other day my friend Ed was
like hey does your phone do this and he
held it up to my ear and just slightly
went like this